sie sprechen die zeit an viel zeit hat
kim zierold nicht weil er verzweifelt
auf einen impfstoff wartet und sich
vergessen fühlen herr zierold sie
erleben diese debatte momentan sie
sitzen mit muskelschwäche im rollstuhl
müssen eine atemmaske getragen und
bekommen keine impfung bislang wie viel
angst haben sie vor corona und was
sollte die politik was sollte hier
einsparen aus ihrer sicht tun
also ich habe jacko fans richtet sich
unter anderem bei den pflegekräften ich
vermutlich eine rolle endlich so richtig
verdient werde könnten sie dafür sorgen
dass ich so schnell wie möglich der sehr
können
ersparen was können sie tun wie können
sie ganz persönlich helfen
das ist ja das ziel auch menschen die
eine vorerkrankung haben wir jetzt hier
rollt und die natürlich nachvollziehbar
sehr große sorge haben sich zu
infizieren weil das risiko natürlich
damit ein großes ist auch
schnellstmöglich zu impfen und
gleichzeitig bleibt eben das problem
dass wir im moment nicht ausreichend
impfstoff haben um alle die tatsächlich
ein erhöhtes risiko haben gleichzeitig
oder jetzt in den ersten wochen zu
impfen
und das ist das wie naja wie in der
gesellschaft wie in der familie wir
müssen jetzt gerade ein knappes gut
verteilen und dann ist sozusagen in der
familie die die die großmutter da die 83
jährige mit einem risiko ist vielleicht
eine tochter in der familie erzieherin
mit einem risiko im berufsalltag
es gibt vielleicht jemand einer familie
mit einer sehr schweren vorerkrankungen
und jetzt hat man halt eine dose man
weiß man wird alle impfungen können in
den nächsten wochen aber heute steht nur
eine dose zur verfügung war jetzt ist
nicht mal in der prioritätenliste auf
platz eins oder zwei er kommt wenn das
so weiter geht erst in monaten ist das
gerät der vorerkrankung ohne dass ich
jetzt das krankheitsbild und detail
kenne wäre es nach meiner einschätzung
priorisierung gruppe 2 aber das ist ja
eine frage die haben das ist ja ich will
dass nur noch mal erläutern das ist eine
total schwere frage es ist es in der
familie in so einer situation wenn würde
man dann impfen und das ist weil
natürlich jeder ich doch auch sofort
intuitiv sagen würde erzählt sie sollten
eigentlich jetzt sofort ihre impfung
bekommen können das ist klar dass das
sofort intuitiv doch nahe liegt wenn das
risiko da ist und gleichzeitig müssen
wir es ja irgendwie versuchen jedenfalls
so gerecht wie möglich zu machen
deswegen haben wir die ständige
impfkommission gebeten auf basis von
risikoanalysen im zu sagen wo ist das
risiko am größten und das risiko wenn
sie jetzt mal die gesamtbevölkerung
nehmen ist bei den über 80 jährigen und
den pflegebedürftigen wenn wir das
ausbruchsgeschehen am größten aber
individuell natürlich dann doch da was
ist geben kann
das haben wir ja auch schon gesehen sind
einzelfall entscheidungen in so einer
situation die sozusagen
von so einer generellen für alle
gültigen reihenfolge gar nicht getroffen
oder oder abgebildet sein können
aber ja es ist eine recht schwierige
situation doch schwierig das plausibel
und verständlich zu machen warum jetzt
die einen früher dran sind als die
anderen aber bei dieser knappheit müssen
wir eben am ende nach bestimmten
kriterien entscheiden
hertie rollt sie haben gehört was der
minister zu ihrem fall gesagt hat und so
prioritätenliste stellt sie das
zufrieden
das ist schon seit vier wochen versuche
derzeit derzeit ob twitter com dieser
text weiter catcher genanntes
angeschrieben bis zum teil weit über der
theke oder vielen vielen dank
wir können eines versprechen von bild
wir werden uns dafür einsetzen werden an
allen stellen in niedersachsen auch
nachfragen was da passiert ist und warum
sie keine antwort bekommen herzlichen
dank